we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the number
is available to you anytime of day it's
also available for whatever reason you
want if you have something you want to
ask about that's not directly related to
politics if I find it interesting I
might still answer and here's one such
example take a listen to this voicemail
hey David do you believe that baseball
was better during the steroid era i hear
that argument and quite frankly I simply
don't buy it because I have been Tegrity
for the game yeah you know what I was
significantly more into baseball during
the steroid era but it didn't have
anything to do with the steroids it was
just I had more time to sit around and
watch close to 160 to baseball games a
year for the Red Sox and I just followed
it much more closely so I am sort of the
wrong person to say that baseball was
better during the steroid steroid era or
it is better now
in the limited baseball I watch it does
seem very anecdotally that there are
fewer homeruns being hit and my guess is
that some portion of that would be
related to the crackdown on steroids and
the realization that a whole hell of a
lot of those people hitting 40 50 60 or
more home runs a year were juicing I
think that the what am what's important
to me is that there be some kind of a
level playing field okay so if baseball
said listen steroids will help you in
some ways and in others it's skill and
it's practice and here is the list of
sort of approved substances I really
wouldn't have a problem with that like
we could make arguments about purity of
the game we could make arguments about
well the records now have to be
considered different than the records
eighty years ago because of the
substances that are now available those
are all legitimate arguments and quite
frankly I'm fine
saying let's just do it a clean game no
steroids whatsoever but I don't think
there's anything objectively wrong with
saying this is a sport that allows the
following performance enhancements and
that's it when you think about even just
what we know about nutrition for
baseball players may be more relevant in
other sports basketball football
whatever you can argue
that the gains that are had via our
knowledge of nutrition today are also in
a way responsible for so many of the
records of 80 years ago being broken
it's not performance-enhancing in an
illicit way but it is also a sort of
better understanding of science and
substances that allows players to do
things that players were not doing 80
years ago there's also some interesting
statistical stuff related to why does it
always seem that previously
unsurpassable records are surpassed and
there's some interesting statistical
stuff there that is sort of beyond the
scope of this segment which I find
interesting and encourage you to check
out but I don't really care that much
about steroids in baseball i watch very
little baseball either way when the Red
Sox do well I start following and
otherwise I'm just sort of too busy but
for me personally I was definitely
paying more attention to baseball during
the steroid era but not because of the
steroids just because I was in college
and everybody around me was watching
every Red Sox game and it was a big part
of my social life we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about States considering revoking
religious vaccine exemptions we will
also talk about a Denver vote this week
on decriminalizing hallucinogenic
mushrooms which we've been following
actually since the beginning and we'll
also talk about Democrats of faltering
in voter enthusiasm for 2020 which could
be a problem all of those stories and
more and I will be joined by producer
Pat in his new role as supervising
producer of the David Pakman show in
mere minutes on the bonus show
make sure you remember in order to
access it